[Music]
Christian
hello
everyone I say everyone but I feel like
everyone's at home watching the Cowboys
game it's kind of empty
no that's what DVR is for I'm recording
it no spoilers nobody talked to me about
it um well I'm miam I think I've met or
talked to all of you if not nice to meet
you all I'd love to chat with you come
on in chat with you uh after service say
hello um give you a high five hug
whatever you'd like uh got a couple of
announcements before we get into service
today and I realized that I brought my
most broken notebook today so I'm hoping
this doesn't like fall apart on me if it
does I apologize um couple of
announcements so relationship class
survey so we are looking to have a class
about relationships with significant
others this fall um we'd love your input
on topics that you might find
interesting or beneficial and potential
times that would work for you if you are
interested so if if that is of any
interest to you there is going to be a
QR code up on the screen um as always
you can scan that and fill out that
information please do it please do
it uh second announcement I'm sorry I
feel like I'm getting loud and quiet and
trying to accommodate uh centerpiece
conference so something I haven't
personally attended but it's something I
heard about through the table a couple
of years ago so every two years years
lgbtq Christians and allies gather from
all over the country here in Dallas um
and it's a three-day conference called
this centerpiece conference so this year
it's October 24th through the 26th if
you're looking to connect with
likeminded people um or just wanting
some resources to help you get through
different types of theology about being
open and confirming I mean affirming
this is a great event for you um to
attend
so we've got a couple of things that
we're going to do um before we get into
worship um the first thing I'm going to
do is candle lighting and then our
called The Worship so as you're willing
and able I'd ask you to stand uh so we
can get prepared for
that yes of course
so these candles are a sign of the
presence of Christ Among Us fully Divine
and fully
human now we exit the kingdom of noise
hurry and
productivity now we enter the kingdom of
of Silence Stillness and
simplicity Sacred Space a place for
prayer worship and adoration a place to
behold Christ revelation of God
heartbeat of
creation allow The unforced rhythms of
Grace to find you to mend your heart may
we all come home
maram you guys can remain standing we're
going to go ahead and start with the
song that we learned last week if you
were with us so you guys sing along if
you remember it and if not feel free to
join in um we're really glad you're here
[Music]
let's sing Mercy Rising
Mercy Rising with the rising of the
[Music]
sun
goodness rushing in and filling up our
lungs sing your fa
your
faithfulness is here and
now the
evidence is all
around I bless I bless your name I give
you praise today is a day for
singing Awake My Soul come on and praise
the Lord
today is a day for singing sing all my
soul my
soul
praise the
Lord
oh my
soul today is a day for singing
new
song is Welling from deep inside of
[Music]
me there is new
light Hallelujah I have been redeemed
I've been
redeemed I bless your
name I give you praise to today is a day
for
[Music]
singing Awake My Soul come on and praise
the Lord today is a day for
singing sing Oh My Soul
oh my
[Music]
soul
PR the
Lord oh
my
soul today today is a day for
[Music]
singing the valley
the to
the I will
[Music]
praise as I am Brea
a day for singing let's sing that again
the
valley to the
Fountain oh I will praise
you from the morning to the evening as I
am Brea today is a day for singing today
today today is a day
singing oh today today is a day for
singing sing I bless your name I bless
your
name I give you
praise today is a day for
singing oh wake my soul come on and
praise the Lord today is a day for
singing
he know my soul
oh my soul
yeah the
[Music]
Lord my
soul today is a day for
singing sing it
again soul
the
[Music]
morning I am
breathing is a day for
singing to today is a day for
singing today is a day for
[Music]
sing all right y are dismissed to your
classes your teachers will meet you over
there by the doors and take you
back youall have
fun and we're going to go ahead and
transition into the prayers of the
people um if it's your first time just
read along with the sections in red you
can say those aloud with us and then
when we pause in the middle you can
offer up a prayer that's on your heart
for someone or a situation that you are
carrying into this space tonight and we
will hold that together before
God Jesus for this city of saxi Texas
and for every city and community and all
who live in them we pray to you for the
Good Earth you have given us and the
wisdom and the will to conserve it we
pray to you for the old and the sick for
the Widow and orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to you for the poor
and the oppressed the unemployed and
destitute for prisoners and captives and
all who remember and care for them we
pray to you for the vulnerable the
marginalized and those unjustly targeted
for their gender sexuality race or
perceived difference we pray to you for
those experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you Lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us so we lift these names
and situations up to you
for the names and moments that we have
spoken aloud and those that we have kept
in our hearts we pray to you that they
may have life and
light healing and hope peace and a deep
sense of your presence amen
[Music]
God bring you the work of our and now
lay it
down
we've we bu were we
broken lay it down lay it your
feet you
hold
all Jesus you
hold it
[Music]
all we
lay it down lay
your we used we lost We
wased Lay It Down
lay
your you
hold Jesus you hold it
you
hold
it Jesus you
hold it all
[Music]
dreams
lay to
[Music]
fruition lay it down lay it
your
feet We Lay It
Down lay
it this week I was reading a book um
called woven I think maybe the Kaisers
passed it on to us and um of the things
that it was talking about was um how we
as people are
so complicated and so diverse and so
layered and um yet sometimes we want God
to somehow be able to be like boiled
down into something that we can
understand something that we can make
sense of that his plans will make sense
to us that the ways that he is just will
always seem according to what we think
they should be um and yet that's not the
god that we love that's not the god that
we see in the Bible that's not even the
god that I've come to know as a follower
of Jesus is not someone that I can make
sense of not a God that answers the
prayers that seem very much like a
prayer that he would want to answer you
know and um what I love about the lyrics
of that last song that that third verse
says and even if nothing comes to
fruition We Lay It down and I just feel
like there's several things in my own
life that I can look back at that I
really wanted to come to fruition and it
didn't happen and sometimes we spend a
lot of energy even money time resources
our hopes and dreams our Ambitions
pouring into something that in the end
may not even come
about and somehow in that I want to be
able to make sense of it but in the lens
of just you know God I just want to know
that you're holding it with me sometimes
that can be enough in the moment where I
just don't understand just knowing that
he's holding it with me can be
enough and that we have a god who's big
enough to hold all of the complexities
all the mystery and to trust that
somehow some way he is weaving it
together for our good he is weaving it
together for his good for a better story
for Justice and
love for things that I may not even have
a glimmer of yet but he's holding it he
can hold it so this last song Caleb and
Maggie are going to lead it for us and
um I just want us to reflect on
that sometimes it's just enough to lay
it down to give it over to him and say
whatever I do have I'm trusting you with
it I want I want you to be a God that I
can trust I want you to be big enough
I want you to be good enough in the
end so will you guys go ahead
and sing this
[Music]
song how can I
respond how can I
respond to the love that you
have
on me
how can I
respond to the love that
[Music]
you I don't
have I don't
have but I have a heart thats for you I
have a heart that beats for you I don't
have
I
don't but I have a heart thats for I
have a heart thats for
[Music]
you of
wants to love
[Music]
you
of to you
you I don't have
much I don't have much but I have heart
that beats for you I have a heart that
beats for you I don't
have I don't have much but I have a
heart that beats for you I have a heart
that beats for you I have a heart that
beats for you I have a heart that beats
for you I have a heart that beats for
you I have a heart thats for you I have
a life I'll give to you I have a life
I'll give to you I have a life I'll give
to you I have a life I'll give to you I
have a heart that beats for you I have a
heart that beats for you I have a heart
that beats for you I have a heart that
beats for you I have a life I'll give to
you I have a life I'll give to you I
have a life I'll give to you I have a
life I'll give to
you I don't have
much I don't have much but I have a
heart that beats for you I have a heart
that beats for you I don't have
much I don't have much but I have a
heart that beats for you I have a heart
that beats for
you God we give you our
heart we give you our
plans our hopes our
worries our frustrations
our
anger our
doubt we lay it
down we want to trust you with it
God we want to believe that you are with
us in the
valley and you are with us on the
mountain
you are with us when we make our bed in
the
depths and when we sore on the heights
with eagles God you are there you see
us you have made
us help us to make room for you for your
plan
for your
ways help us to adopt your vision and
your
heart keep doing your good work in us
God in Jesus name
amen can you guys turn to the people
around you make them feel welcome say
hello e
well Grace and peace good to be with you
all really really good I hope you had a
a good week and uh yeah a joy a joy to
be with you that includes those joining
us online love you all Lots um and
anyone here tonight who is new thank you
for for being with us Among Us so um
tonight is the Sixth and final part in
our series titled The Parables of Jesus
and uh parables are these short stories
that Jesus used um to teach and so we've
just been you know kind of making our
way through a number of these and so the
title of my message this week finishing
with a good one a famous One the parable
of the Good
Samaritan and uh you know before we kind
of read the story I want to give you
some of the background that kind of sets
up the the whole Parable so uh an expert
in religious
law comes to Jesus and he's as sort of
the various religious leaders at that
time were doing he's trying to kind of
trip Jesus up try to catch him you know
uh so he asks him uh what must I do to
inherit eternal
life and Jesus kind of fuzzy often does
uh flips the question around and asks
him a question so he says well what does
the law say right the religious law and
this expert in the law replies well to
love the Lord Lord your God with all
your heart soul mind and strength and to
love your neighbor as yourself and Jesus
says you've answered
beautifully and the man isn't you know
doesn't want the conversation to end so
he says
uh and and who is my
neighbor and it's at that point Jesus
doesn't ask him another followup
question like well what does the law say
no uh he doesn't quote even like another
scripture or something to him instead he
tells him a
story and so here we are Luke 10 verses
30 through
37 in reply Jesus said A man was going
down from Jerusalem to Jericho which if
you know the geography it is quite a
steep descent so it is literally
down when he was attacked by robbers
they stripped him of his clothes beat
him and went away leaving him half dead
a priest happened to be going down the
same road and when he saw the man he
passed
by on the other side so too a levite was
like the helpers of the priests when he
came to the place and saw him passed by
on the other side but a Samaritan as he
traveled came where the man was and when
he saw him he took pity on him
he went to him and bandaged his wounds
pouring on oil and wine these
instruments of you know
healing then he put the man on his own
donkey and brought him to an inn and
took care of him the next day he took
out two daeri gave them to the inkeeper
look after him he said and when I return
I will reimburse you for any extra
expense you may
have which of these three do you think
was a neighbor to the man who fell into
the hands of
robbers the expert in the law
replied the one who had mercy on
him Jesus told him go and do
likewise now if you're
familiar with this
story then you you know kind of the The
Twist which is not only that of course
right the religious leaders the the
people who you would expect to stop and
care and right these are folks trained
in the ways of God and so if anyone's
going to you know live the ways of God
well it's them right uh so it's not only
that you would expect them to stop the
The Twist of course is that it's a
Samaritan who stopped who was the one to
offer Aid now the trick is that in our
own culture
um the word Samaritan that that language
is uh well for us it's come to mean kind
of the opposite of what it meant right
that when we think like if I were to say
Samaritan many of us would think the
Good Samaritan right so thus Samaritans
are good uh but that's of course sort of
the inheritance of a few thousand years
of culture and being familiar with this
story that now in our minds we associate
Samaritan Good Good Samaritan uh but of
course that's kind of the twist in the
story is that for those first hearers
and this expert in religious law uh if
you're familiar with the history there
uh the Samaritans the Jewish people um
were there was I mean there's like a
whole history going back to the I think
it was the Assyrian conquest and anyway
they're basically kind of ethnic
religious um kind of enemies and there's
a lot of tension between them so of
course right that's kind of the the
twist in the story is that it's
precisely the last person that the
expert in religious law would expects to
be the one to stop right that's of
course precisely who uh Jesus has uh
stopping in this uh version so I mean it
would be a little bit like say uh you
know a preacher standing up in like
1950s Alabama to this kind of like you
know white congregation and telling a
story where like the local Pastor passes
by and the local you know Elder
leadership team member passes by or the
Deacon you know whatever and then uh an
African-American man is the noble one is
the righteous one is the the true
neighbor to this broken man right um or
it it could be sort of like maybe in
like an Evangelical congregation in like
the years following
911 right to say the the pastor passes
by and whoever uh but then it's it's uh
a Muslim woman who stops and is the hero
of the story right or in our own context
right if I were to preach the version of
this where it's like a I don't know it's
like some very conservative
person waving their patriotic flag or
something and they're the one who stops
and cares for the the person in need
right that's the the kind of impact
that's kind of the The Twist of the
story The the point being of course that
uh kind of love and neighborliness which
means here more than just like the
people live next to you I mean this this
kind of you know love for Humanity uh
extends
Beyond is not restricted to this group
or that group this tribe or that
tribe right instead love and
neighborliness it's less about
ideology or even kind of
theology though um I do think you know
ideology Theology and such
matters but in the end the the question
is much more how do I respond to this
person in all their particularity like
right here right
now right in essence um the kind of
disturbing point of the story is that I
could genuinely believe that I have like
the best theology the best political
Theory the best moral
philosophy and and I
do as we all suspect we do you know it's
like or else we'd believe something else
you know so it's like we can genuinely
believe like I I have the best and
yet it's someone with who I perceive has
the worse theology political Theory
moral philosophy etc etc etc who ends up
out neighboring
me who ends up actually
like
living
it expressing it in the body you know
like hands I mean you can see it in the
story oil and wine and donkeys and money
and you know hotels and like it's it's
all like very kind of earthy and
practical
and and that's like where it begins to
happen right in essence I could say like
I'm a better neighbor in
theory but they could be like a better
neighbor in
reality so with that kind of question in
mind I want us to be meditating tonight
on um on this I should say this question
um what hinders our
helping what is it that hinders our help
helping I mean I think we all have I
know y'all like we have good intentions
you know no one's like no I don't want
to be a neighbor no like no no even I
think we're all like yes it's a
beautiful story like yes this is what
the world needs you know just
transcending the boundaries and like
loving people and serving and caring I
mean I was there uh just yesterday at
five loes food pantry where number of
you were there like do doing the thing
you know packing boxes with food and
handing it putting in Trunks and you
know like and I think we're all like
yeah like this is great this is yes the
the trick is we like walk out those
doors and somehow I I don't know about
you for me it's just life just eats me
alive it just eats all my good
intentions alive and before I know it
I'm like back here on Sunday and it's
been real hard
all week to like be that neighbor to
live in those ways to see and respond
like it's so hard so that's kind of the
question is why what is it like think
seriously about it what is it that
hinders our helping your helping uh
Richard Beck has some wonderful blog
posts on this topic if you don't know
who Richard Beck is oh my gosh Google a
man and read his blog experimental
theology. blogspot.com I know you're
like I don't read blogs anymore well
you're lost they're so good it's so good
um but he mentioned I'm going to link to
him in my EET this week some of his
posts on this whole Parable and such but
he mentioned specifically one study this
week that I was just I was nerding out
over it's so good so the study he didn't
do it but he just referenced it the
study was done um let's see way back it
was like 1973 by John Farley and Daniel
bat
it was titled from Jerusalem to Jericho
a study of situational and dispositional
variables in helping Behavior which is a
fancy way of saying what hinders our
helping so here was their kind of social
experiment and as all like good social
experiments are I was like devilishly
clever you know where you get a bunch of
people in a room and they think they're
being experimented for one thing but
they're not you know it's something
that's the whole point they can't know
what they're being you know what I mean
or else it messes it up so I mean it was
it was it was really genius so okay so
in this um basically in short they
recreated sort of an aspect of the Good
Samaritan story they gathered up all
these Seminary students right folks who
presumably like they're like the priests
and the levite right these are folks
being trained for Christian Ministry
they love the lord they're headed
towards you know some sort of full-time
Ministry or whatever exactly that means
but you know they're kind of they're
doing thing right so gathers them all up
and I think it was like 40 50 students
or so and then divided them uh into two
groups they thought they were basically
being judged on a talk they were giving
so they were given two different topics
one was um invited to basically read
reflect and then give a little
presentation on the story of you guessed
it the Good Samaritan so that's like
half the other half was told to just
prepare a a talk on a non-h helping
topic so they sent them off and told
them to uh be back at like this
particular location on campus this day
this time you know prepare the talk be
there at that time okay time goes by
they show up they each had like
different slots they're not like showing
up all at once you know they kind of
have these time slots so as they showed
up they were kind of further divided
into like kind of three sub groups and
this was about um time pressure so
basically one group showed up and they
were given a a sense of urgency they're
basically told it's sort of like your
worst nightmare they're told like oh my
gosh okay you're here we've change the
location of the talk it started five
minutes ago you need to be across campus
at such and such Val some of you are
kind of Moaning just oh gosh your
anxiety is like going through the roof
you so the second kind of subg group was
given moderate time pressure so it was
oh so glad you're here you have time but
it's the location's been changed so you
need to leave now I think you can make
it on time though but just leave now the
third group was like it was chill s like
oh hey okay you're here actually it
changed location but no worries you know
might as well head over now though um
just to make sure you're there early you
know so it's kind of like these
different kind of things right I said
devilishly clever like it was so now
here's the The Twist though the path
they had to take take it was like to
this back alley and they had of course
placed a person there an actor someone
who was suffering they were instructed
that as each person walked by this for
this actor they were to cough
twice and then let out one moan I think
it's for the study because they need it
to be the same each time you know what I
mean like the kind of the social science
cough twice one good moan as each
student walks by
and then they were there this person
then kind of recorded how each person
responded so okay so how did this play
out right because in Ence they're kind
of the question that's driving it is
sort of three things one is like these
are all kind of christiany you know
students and such like maybe they'll all
stop right second how did the story of
the Good Samaritan kind of factor in
like did those who were all weak
thinking reflecting on the story would
they be more likely to stop
uh as opposed to those just you know
been doing their non-h helping topic and
then third how did the hurry kind of
factor you know play in okay so here's
what they found um first not everyone
stopped not even close um
second the uh the there was absolutely
no difference between those who were
primed by the story of the Good
Samaritan and those who were not which
is very disappointing for me as a
preacher
they think like don't worry y'all we've
we've been thinking about this you know
all today so tomorrow we're for sure
going to hit it out of the park you know
like yeah probably not again because we
walk out those doors and life just eats
Us Alive you know it just it just
happens uh so yeah so that was kind of
disappoint that that didn't factor in um
in short it was all about the hurry it
was all about that it was something
about
60% of the children group stopped those
who had felt like they had time weren't
under the time pressure they stopped
40ish perent was like 43 or something
per of the moderate group stopped to
check in
10% of those who were in The hurry mode
stop in other words
90% did not in fact the the kind of
victim the actor there who was laying on
the ground reported that some of the
students who were in The High hurry
group literally stepped over them in the
alley to get where they were going when
they when they talked to these students
afterwards and asked them like kind of
debriefed you know with the experience
and such they said um kind asked them
like what was your mindset and such and
it was interesting they said honestly I
didn't even tune into
it like in other words it wasn't so much
they're like oh gosh that person
suffering I just don't have time I'm so
sorry the Lord bless you and keep you I
got to go you know it wasn't that it was
more like
like they were
going does that resonate with anyone
it's not so much yeah I don't care about
people you know no it's more like I'm
just
going I'm just going I'm on a mission
here a mission through this thing called
my
life and
that's that's
where we start to struggle
in short right it wasn't so much they're
making a conscious decision to ignore
the suffering instead the greater the
sense of hurry the more unconscious
unaware unintentional they
became the poet uh Jack
Gilbert wrote these words I quote this
at least once a year so it's time for
the annual I love this the grand Italian
churches are covered with detail which
is visible at the pace people walk
by the great modern buildings are
blank because there is no time to see
from the
car a thousand years ago when they built
The Gardens of
kiyoto the stones were set in the
streams a skew whoever went
quickly would fall
in when we
slow the garden can choose what we
notice can change our
heart a few years ago a friend of mine
began uh kind of visiting attending a uh
a different Church in the area and uh
the pastor was super gifted Great
Communicator great administrator man
that church it ran like a well-oiled
machine just
remarkable um one day this friend he was
in a uh I think it was like a grocery
was going grocery stopping or something
and he saw a woman there in the parking
lot having car trouble was like the
classic you
know just struggling battery the whole
you know situation so he he stops and uh
checks on her I think they tried to jump
it it was like to no
avail so she's like you know what my
husband he works like locally let me
give him give him a call you know and
see if he can come and maybe then I can
go and pick up a battery and you know
you can do the the whole thing and my
friend is like okay sure sure here I'll
just I'll just wait you know until you
get a hold of him you can get here and
you can be on your way and so he did he
waited around she and she called him uh
pretty soon 15 minutes later so the
husband you know shows up and he was
hopping mad my friend couldn't believe
it honestly he's like shocked you know
um this husband he was just so like ter
ticked off and he literally looked at
his wife and he yelled at her and he
said you know how busy I
am like what why H basically how can you
bother me with these sorts of things
like I you know I don't have time for
this the man was of course the pastor at
the church he'd been visiting
recently now the trick is right I think
we can kind of throw stones at least
mental stones at the at the bastard but
I think this is the trick the truth is
most if not all of us are kind of caught
up in what I'll call this massive
Collective illness this kind of cultural
hysteria you know no one's immune not
even spiritual leaders or
helpers Among Us right in short no one
has any
time teachers no time pastors no time
parents no time managers no time there's
just like no time really to be
human nearly all of us are in that hurry
manipulated group aren't
we so what do we do you know I admit um
I don't think there's any like quick
fixes here you know where it just like
oh yeah just quit your job just quit
everything empty the calendar you know I
don't I don't think it's quite that that
easy uh in said I think there's some
real soul
searching we have to do
here second question ask yourself why
the
rush why the
rush and probably the first answers will
be a lot of like justifications you know
what I mean just like I I don't got a
choice and
I you know but then kind of get
underneath that you know and then just
like ask it again like why the rush in
other words what's the fear what's the
longing what's the what's the desire
what's the dread you know
underneath the
crazy I think back on those students in
the
study right why the rush for them I mean
cuz sitting here we can kind of see like
it doesn't matter like it wasn't even
your fault you know mean like chill out
but of course for them why the rush well
they're anxious they're anxious they've
got a very important presentation to
give you know so so for them why the
rush anxiety right it it wasn't a big
deal but it felt huge to them and so
they literally stepped over the hurting
person to go deliver their talk about
about caring for the
hurting this uh came across this quote
from James Finley I just included this
this morning so it's not on the screen
but um it's this the unessential
constantly imposes itself upon
us the essential never
does why the rush I think of the the
priest and the levite in the parable the
text says they were going down right
down from from Jerusalem to Jericho so
from the temple where they worked to
Jericho where they lived so in other
words they're kind of they're on their
way home after a long shift so why the
rush for them you know they just wanted
to get home you know they were
tired maybe they were even just afraid
of um being hurt by the very robbers
that hurt that man you know in other
words why the rush for them may it was
as simple as a just plain old fear
personally for me the answer to the
question why the rush is well I don't
want to be a
failure busy people are successful
people you know what I mean and I want
to be a successful person I do I admit
it so why the rush so I don't fail you
know or at least so I'm not perceived by
others as a failure
so that's me but I guess the question is
what is it for
you why the
rush plunge into those Waters this week
May we all be wrestling with these
questions what hinders my helping why
the rush in the name of the Father the
Son and the Holy Spirit
amen so as we uh come to the
table of the Lord Lord as we take in the
body of Christ in the bread the blood of
Christ in the cup may we carry those two
questions in our
heart may we take it slow may we allow
God to change um what we notice to
change our hearts in the process so the
way we'll partake in communion tonight
is we'll start with this front row and
we'll just work our way back um we
practice what's called an Open Table
meaning if you're here tonight and you'd
like to participate then you're free to
do that you should know that the red is
wine the white is grape juice and then
finally you can just partake whenever
and however you'd like so this is the
table not of the church but of the Lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more so come you who have much faith and
you who have little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long you who have
tried to follow and you who
failed come because it's the Lord Jesus
himself who invites you and it's his
will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here come to the table
before we sing this last song um I just
want to feel free to sing with it if you
know it um it means a lot to me this
song is uh it's almost like a pinned
letter from anybody that grew up in uh
in the church um you know the chorus you
know the first line is I'm so sorry for
how it's been um you know I had a my
roommate in college um he was a gay man
and uh he didn't get
to experience the church like experience
to he um and he never felt like he could
be
himself
and you know singing through this song
well I didn't know it was going to hit
me like this
um it's almost like a pen letter to him
uh from me just saying I'm sorry that it
was this way man I wish you could have
experienced um the church in its pure
form um so if you know what sing along
I'm going to try and get through it
um
[Music]
yeah you're gay and over
85 you felt for your whole life God Made
You
just messed
up you've been raised a Southern bell
born and Bre for show and tell lie down
feeling never good
enough I'm so
sorry how it's
[Music]
been we're broken
artist with broken pin
pain our
pride call it
truth sorry no one explain Jesus
[Music]
to if you heard a knock on your front
door all you found on the porch was a
pastor that just wanted to be
right if you really want to pray to him
but you're never sure he is
now who could forgive what you did last
night I'm so
sorry for what you
heard were broken poets
with silly
words with pain
agendas call it
truth sorry no one explain Jesus to
[Music]
you I can feel him in this room
oh all he really wants is
you I'm so
sorry for all the
wrong we're broken
singers broken
songs we paint our
pride call it
truth sorry no one explained Jes Jesus
to
you sorry no one explain Jesus to
you sorry no one explain Jesus to you
as always thank you to Brett and the
worship team for um music I've never end
the sermon tonight but I've never heard
that song before um definitely hits in a
lot of different good ways um so I
appreciate y'all sharing
that want to thank everyone for joining
us this
evening if you are a visitor this is
your first second third time we want to
get to know you more um I would
encourage you to scan that code up on
the QR code up on the screen essentially
it'll let us give us the opportunity to
reach out to you and see how we can be
there for you um in any way that you
need us just generally thank you for
visiting us if you're in need of any
sort of prayer hug word of encouragement
come find me after service I'm happy to
do so um high five whatever you need
come find me um happy to be there for
you
giving is a big um aspect as how we are
able to grow here at the table um I
would encourage you if you haven't done
so go ahead and check out you know our
mission statements things of that nature
see what we stand for and if you choose
to support us you can scan the QR code
as well get that information um I know
as Brett said life gets pretty busy and
days and months Roll by and you know
it's easy for to forget so at least with
this I have it on auto recurring thing
and I've mentioned that before but that
helps me um and it's definitely helpful
for us as a community to be able to
serve um you all and the people in the
community I'm going to go ahead and send
us out with a benediction um to lead you
through this
week feel free to receive this in any
sort of way that you're that you feel
comfortable you are a child of God
you are a child of
God this is true on your best day and
this is especially true on your worst
day so as you go into your week ahead
with its yet to be determined highs and
lows and everything in
between go filled with the assurance
that you are loved you are worthy and
you are accepted just the way that you
are and go filled with God's Holy Spirit
and the desire to extend these same
Gifts of Grace and unconditional love to
everyone that you come in contact with
be blessed we hope to see you next
[Music]
Sunday you feel him in room
really want is
you I'm so
sorry all the
wrong broken
singers broken
songs pain our
pride call it
truth sorry no one explain Jesus to you
for